en matière d'orientation les grands
classiques ont toujours du succès en
témoigne l'engouement perpétuelle pour
le métier d'infirmier si on aime
françois des os c'est ne pas s'occuper
cas de ce soir c'est un beau métier un
métier d'avenir
à l'issue de la formation les infirmiers
ont tous un emploi
autre grand succès les métiers du
numérique avec un vaste choix de
formations proposées et de nouveaux
débouchés ou sous des applications
smartphones aujourd'hui tout le monde a
un téléphone portable sur lequel il à
différentes applications
donc c'est ce qu'on nous apprenons entre
autres à nos étudiants chaque année
apparaissent de nouvelles formations
tandis que d'autres sont retirés au
rectorat
un observatoire travail avec l'insee sur
les besoins réels des entreprises mais
pas seulement on regarde le taux de
chômage aussi mais par contre ça ne peut
pas être seuls éléments parce que
n'oubliez pas que les jeunes font des
demandes par rapport à leur serait pas
forcément par rapport à l'offre sur le
marché du travail mais surtout par
rapport à ce qu'ils ont envie de faire
partir ou rester étudié en martinique la
question se pose aussi au salon le
retrouve écoles américaines universités
du québec marc bad jamaïque
je pense que ce sera sûrement
intéressant réparations parce que ça à
pois au code nip aux horizons et pour
qu'on va permettre de découvrir un petit
peu
il revenir sur tourments scénique pour
ramener tout ce que j'ai appuyé et
améliorer la du jeu vient saluer ici il
y aussi ceux qui feront leur vie très
loin comme françois regina originaire de
basse pointe son association image in
japan a déjà aidé 40 jeunes à trouver un
stage au pays du soleil levant
il ya eu la question qui se pose que les
jeunes quittent la martinique etc
moi ça fait huit ans que je vis au japon
et j'agis de la martinique de façon tout
en restant au japon je vis pour la
martinique
j'ai un impact est justement sur la
martinique la diaspora martinique est un
terreau l'important auprès de nos jeunes
un soutien mais aussi une inspiration